can you go back to Google and Amazon's
IPOs and just give Founders who maybe
were in college when that happened and
weren't playing the game or investors
who weren't on the field what the the
footprint of those companies were and
you know there was a little trepidation
I think going public at that time as
well for both of those companies yeah it
wasn't perfect either Google was a
Google was a little bigger because they
did this whole planned auction thing and
so it was it I think they were bigger
but Amazon went public I think you know
only after a Kleiner investment I don't
think they ever did a beat um and they
were they were like 70 million in
revenue or something they were really
small Salesforce Salesforce went public
60 million of current year Revenue
doubling year-over-year so it's going
from 60 to 120 went public at a billion
dollars yeah we took Open Table public
doing $10 million a quarter so a 40
million run rate and and so it's all
it's all possible like you know it's
just a question of whether you're cool
with the valuation and you got to get a
bank who doesn't insist that you raise
$200 million because that might not work
with the with with the valuation that
you're going to have to accept but but
but I do think we'll see some people
move through you know it's one of those
things it's going to take a leader and
then you have one and then you'll have
two and then you'll have three strip the
likely candidate bill you would say
stripe's the one blocking uh everybody
psychologically that is like all the big
ones you know they can go whenever they
want I I don't think that really opens
things up I think we need I think we
need some leaders from from from non
Mega companies to help to help you know
build the path you know hey Bill one one
thing that we don't often say but I
think might be true as well what emerged
over the last 10 years was a new class
of investors they call themselves maybe
Venture investors but I really think of
them as investing in quasi public
companies these are companies with over
you know kind of a billion dollar
valuation they're late stage investors
and you know they have a self-interest
in keeping these companies private for a
long time because like private Equity
they can continue to put more and more
capital in it's like a private club for
public market companies that only 50
people can compete for it's a much
better market for you to make money in
than the actual Public Market I don't
think it's better for the founders I
don't think it's better for the
companies but you know in that club R
well I mean the names that that that you
know you know well the crossover
investors the Tigers the co
you know the Green Oaks the altimers of
the world but then I think there's you
know all of these what are the companies
strip strip matches that matches stri B
bite dance SpaceX you know go go through
the list all of these companies could be
public and I think unless you have a
really good reason for the company you
know to stay private I think the public
markets as Amazon as Google as
Salesforce and so many others have
proven this idea that you can't innovate
the public markets it's total nonsense
this idea you know it's a cheap source
of capital it keeps you you know the
business efficient and honest and so my
sense is that you're going to see the
markets really open up in 24 and 25 we
have a backlog because we've had almost
no IPOs two over the course of the last
two years uh and so you know it's just a
matter of price IPO markets are always
wide open Jason it's just a matter of
price what one interesting thing that
that facilitates what Brad was talking
about is we we've become quite
comfortable with secondary and and in
fact when we were going through Zer and
there were people with tons of money in
their pocket and they wanted to cram it
into these companies they would
encourage secondary as a way for them to
get ownership because the founders and
the early investors didn't want more
delution so they would literally you
know knock on doors and say let us help
you do this and if you're a rather large
Angel or early a orb investor or a big
founder you know it's hard for you to
get liquidity through that type of of
mechanism but it relieves a ton of
pressure on the management team for for
the employees to be able to get
liquidity and so you you find yourself
in a forever cycle where these companies
might might stay private for a very very
long time and I think we will see a few
examples and I and I don't know exactly
which company but where that proves to
have been a mistake like for the reasons
Brad talked about and I my favorite my
favorite metaphor here is to is to
imagine a uh football player that goes
from high school to college to Pro and
um you know could you imagine you know
on draft day or a week before draft day
the number one quarterback candidate
says you know I think I'm going to opt
out because you know if I play on Sunday
they're going to they're going to be way
more scrutiny they're going to look
they're going to study all my stats I I
don't think I want to play at that level
or I don't want to play in that
environment and everyone would laugh at
at someone that did that because you
know the the problem is once you've
started handing out options to your
employees once you've take investors
onto your cap chart you're in a game
where your job is to constantly increase
price per share in one day to provide
liquidity to those people and so there's
no there's no way to opt out of that
game you're in the game and the better
you do the harder it gets and so it just
keeps going up but that's the obligation
you have hey Bill did you guys did you
guys wait too long to take Uber public
would you have would you have liked to
seen Uber go public uh before you know
grow started slowing and you know at
evaluation less than whatever it was 50
billion and and so you know we had some
pretty big mistakes and Leasing and
stuff that might have been exposed and
and and dealt with sooner you know as as
Jason has has said on on this and other
podcast if you if you bring up Uber I
have to take a second to just really
really thank um D for all he's done like
cuz the the first job was to clean
things up and put out the fires which he
totally crushed and then the second job
was to increase the value of the company
which is he's starting to deliver on now
and uh yeah makes me very happy so was
no doubt bill in your mind is we're on
the topic of uber and this sort of
speaks to conviction when you see a
billion rides going on and the company's
losing a billion or2 dollar you never
thought like this could never not be
profitable because you knew customers
would pay a little bit more money but
the Press was kind of fixated on this
this can never be profitable this can
never be profitable this business is a
terrible business but the same people
who were saying that were using the
product every day and when the prices
went up and the Venture you know
discount uh and the competition with
lift started to uh recede people had no
problem paying an extra five bucks a
ride three bucks a ride my my my belief
it was all a Zer thing exactly and you
had massive amounts of capital you had a
clear winner in a network effect
business but the um benefits of that
winning were delayed because you had um
Capital being thrown at the second place
player um in a way that that we've never
seen before in the history of venture
but we may be witnessing now in the llm
mark as Bill as bill has described it
which I love you know Capital was used
as a weapon of economic
destruction because the cost of capital
was free and the healthiest and best
thing that's happening to the Venture
Market is the fact that we have interest
rates back at three and a half per.
because you can't have number three
number four number five number six
raiseed Capital to compete dis
economically against the market leader
and that allows the B haers and the
founders and the market leaders to
emerge with profitability profiles much
much
faster yeah was interesting it was a
what a wild experience to see that
amount of capital used that way um first
time in history and people looked at
Amazon as the playbook for that bill I
think they said hey Amazon was never
profitable they they broke even broke
even but they built this huge you know
Revenue base The Tam was huge they you
know look at all the prime subscribers
look at all the adjacent businesses like
AWS they were able to build an
advertising business so there is
something to this I don't want to say
lose money at an alarming rate but a
break even and and build the business
for growth how do you balance that yeah
I mean well well yeah if you know if you
know you have a network effect like how
far do you want to push it and how
aggressive do you want to be and Bezos
you know push you go back to that moment
in time you know between 01 and ' 04
there were multiple times where the
Press was convinced that that Amazon was
going bankrupt and he did have people
chasing him especially in in in
verticals and he he put them all under
part of it was was what we started the
podcast talking about is just the cycle
and he had to adjust his game to the
cycle so in in 7 9798 99 he had
unlimited Capital being thrown at him
and when that changed um he had he did
he did Cuts like he had to do cuts he
had to get to break even
um and eventually he did um yeah so but
look he's one there there are if you
look at at Bezos Benny off and uh let's
say Reed Hastings they all push the edge
of this like like trading off
profitability for growth um and I think
they all did it in a way they were
rewarded for but it it it makes for a a
a uh somewhat frightening ride for the
people that are on the on the uh it's
like going up and down the PCH at like
70 M an hour you're just right along the
edge you're like shouldn't there be a
guard rail here or something no we don't
need guard rails we'll just we'll build
those
later if your landing page looks
terrible customers are just going to
leave they're going to bounce it's 2024
there are no excuses for having an ugly
website so stop settling for okay or
good enough and have an excellent a
beautiful an extraordinary website using
Squarespace it's out of the box
beautiful website designs that will
engage your audience allow you to sell
anything whether it's content or an
actual physical product and you know all
these amazing Squarespace features
you've heard me talk about it before but
they have the most amazing gorgeous
templates to get you off to the races
instantly and those templates they're
all designed and optimized for mobile
this is one of the things that makes me
crazy people will design a website on
their desktop but the consumers 60 70 80
90% of them are experiencing it on their
phones you want to start mobile first
and these templates at Squarespace they
are gorgeous on mobile of course they're
gorgeous on desktop as well and they
have an amazing drag and drop web
designer and you get all kinds of
analytics now you don't have to get
thirdparty tools to do analytics nope
Squarespace baked that all into their
core product you're going to get
marketing analysis sales data and more
directly inside of Squarespace where you
can create an online store or start a
blog or create a subscription business
for members only content and so much
more you do this all simultaneously on
the same platform it's the simplest most
effective and best looking way to start
a business online so here's your call to
action check out squarespace.com twist
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com twist
for 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain